بلغه متشدده اصدر الجيش السوداني بيانا
اكد فيه التزامه صارمه والتامه بالاتفاق
لطريق باكمال العمليه السياسيه في السودان
البيان جاء بعد تصريحات مختلفه تشكك في
التزام قاده الجيش بالعمليه السياسيه تؤكد
قواتكم المسلحه وقيادتها
التزامها التام بمجرات العمليه السياسيه
الجاريه
والتقيد الصارم والتام بما تم التوافق
عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يفضي الى
توحيد المنظومه العسكريه
وقيام حكومه بقياده مدنيه
الموقعون على الاتفاق الايطالي رحبوا
ببيان الجيش ووصفوه بالايجابي وقالوا انه
يدفع باتجاه تحقيق التحول الديمقراطي
ويحفز الاطراف المختلفه على تجاوز
خلافاتها بشان الفتره الانتقاليه البيان
وجد ترحيب من قوى الاطار ترحيب باعتبار ان
هذا موقف محدد ومصرم العبارات
شهدت الايام المنصرمه تباين في وجهات
النظر بين قياده الدعم السريع وقياده
الجيش ولكن هذا البيان اكد ان هناك ليس
هنالك خلاف حول الموقف من العمليه
السياسيه وهو ماشي باننا سنصل الى اتفاق
نهائي قريب لكن الكتله الديمقراطيه التي
تضم عددا من الاحزاب وحركات مسلحه جددت
رفضها الاتفاق الايطالي ودعت الجيش الى
الوقوف على مسافه واحده من كل التنظيمات
السياسيه يبقى الحل في التوافق على اعلان
او اتفاق سياسي جديد تكون كل الاطراف
الفاعله في فتره الانتقال اعضاء في انتاج
هذا الاتفاق بلا استثناء ياتي البيان وسط
تبين في المواقف بين قائد الجيش البرهان
ونائبه قائد قوات الدعم السريع
بشان كيفيه المضي قدما بالعمليه السياسيه
خصوصا ما يتعلق
قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش اضافه الى
احتدام الخلافات بين المكونات المدنيه حول
معايير مشاركه القوى المدنيه في ترتيبات
الفتره الانتقاليه بيان الجيش السوداني
الداعم للاتفاق الايطاليه ربما يحرك جنود
العمليه السياسيه ويسرع خطوات اتفاق ينهي
ازمه باتت تهدد امن واستقرار البلاد بسبب
انتقال الخلافات الى داخل المكون العسكري
الطاهر المرضي الجزيره الخرطوم